Hey Guys,
Thanks for checking out Migrationology.com.
My name is Mark but I sometimes go by Migration
Mark.
After graduating from university in 2008,
I decided to travel around the world and pursue
my passions.
Since then I've been slowly traveling from
place to place learning cultural lessons,
eating as much local street food as possible
and trying to make a little money from my
travel blog along the way.
Migrationology is not only about traveling
around the world, but also about finding a
sustainable way to live your dreams and pursue
your passions!
I am a lover of traveling around the world,
and I am able to continue traveling by maintaining
a travel blog.
Are you ready to take on the Migration?